你有沒有發現
每次你看到
一檔股票在狂漲
表現超好
但只要你一買
它就立刻開始跌
不是因為你運氣差
而是你根本沒有搞懂
成交量的真正用法
成交量聽起來很基本
但實際上
新手只看到數字
不知道它真正意義
很多老手學錯了
自己還不知道
今天這支影片
內容很扎實
所以可能會稍微長一點
但我保證
你可以學到三件事
第一 成交量真正的意義是什麼
第二 要怎麼運用成交量搭配價格
提前判斷股價接下來的走勢
第三 我會告訴你
哪兩種情況最適合進場
答應我
把今天的影片看完
看懂 不要再賠錢了
我是小王子
20年資深交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我們先講最基本的
成交量就是
在某一段時間內
這檔股票實際完成買賣的數量
一般的看盤軟體
會用一根一根的柱子顯示
這根柱子越長 成交得越多
右邊的這個數字
指的是成交的張數
在台股的話
一張就是1000股
所以最後結束的收盤價格
如果比前一次的收盤價更高
這根的柱子就會是紅色
如果收盤價變低了
就會是綠色
很多人看到成交量很大
就會直接以為
是不是很多人
想買這支股票
或是
是不是很多人想要
賣這支股票
但其實
這樣的理解
只對了一半
因為股票要成交
一定要同時有人買
也有人賣
如果大家都想買
但是沒有人願意賣
根本成交不了
所以成交量大
真正代表的意思是
在這個價格附近
買方跟賣方都願意出手
有人覺得這個價格可以買
也有人覺得這個價格可以賣
這也就是成交量最大的價值
因為它不是嘴巴說說而已
而是真的用錢去投票
走出來的價格
就很有參考價值
但你一定要注意
成交量只能告訴你
有多少人
參加了這個價格
不一定代表
它會漲還是會跌
所以成交量的正確用法
一定要搭配股價一起看
才有意義
這就是大家常說的
量價關係
量指的是成交量
價就是股價
你把這兩個東西放在一起看
就能更精確地判斷
現在這檔股票
到底是有力氣繼續往上
還是只是看起來很強
其實快撐不住了
但這裡有一個地方
一堆人都搞錯
很多人學量價關係
都只看兩件事
股價有沒有漲
成交量有沒有放大
然後就開始下結論
但我跟你說
這樣看太粗糙了
因為同一個成交量訊號
放在不同的股價走勢裡
意思會完全不一樣
所以我們的第一步
是要先判斷
現在這檔股票
整體是比較容易往上走
還是整體比較容易往下走
如果你是做中短線投資
可以看20日均線
均線的意思很簡單
它就過去一段時間的收盤價
平均起來再畫一條線
20日均線差不多就是
過去20個交易日
大家買進的平均成本
如果你是做中長線
就可以看60日均線
或120日均線
如果最近的股價
大部分都在均線之上
代表很多人目前是賺錢的
股市的氣氛也比較樂觀
這種情況下
趨勢就容易偏上漲
但如果最近的股價
大部分都在均線下面
代表很多人可能是
買在比較高的位置
現在還沒有賺錢
只要稍微漲上來
就會趕快賣掉
讓股價不容易繼續往上
這種情況下
趨勢就容易偏下跌
做好趨勢判斷之後
我們就可以進入今天
最重要的部分
你只要抓住兩件事
第一 股價是上漲還是下跌
第二 成交量是變大還是變小
這兩個變化組合起來
就會變成四種常見的狀況
第一種叫做價漲量增
意思就是股價上漲
成交量也變大
如果這檔股票本來就處在
上漲的趨勢
像這張圖一樣
股價大部分都會在均線上面
而且股價往上走的時候
成交量也會跟著放大
那這個價漲量增就是好的訊號
因為這代表
股價往上推的時候
有越來越多人願意參與
就算一路有人想要賣
也有買方願意接住
買方接得住
股價才有機會繼續往上推
所以在上漲的漲勢裡
價漲量增
代表這檔股票還有力氣
繼續上漲的機率
就會變得比較高
但是如果這檔股票
原本是下跌的趨勢
那看到價漲量增
就不要太開心了
因為它有可能只是
前面跌太多
所以暫時反彈了一下
看起來好像要反攻
但很快又被跌回去
所以同樣是價漲量增
放在上漲的趨勢
是強勢訊號
但放在下跌的趨勢裡
就可能只是短線的反彈
一下下就跌回去了
接下來看第二種情況
股價漲上去了
但是成交量反而變小
這種叫做價漲量縮
這種情況在不同趨勢裡
差別會更明顯
如果這檔股票
本來是上漲的趨勢
那成交量變小
不一定代表沒有人想要買
很多時候反而是因為
已經買的人
覺得它還會繼續漲
所以想要繼續抱著
不太想賣
賣的人變少
成交量自然會變小
你就算想買
也不一定有人願意賣給你
像這張圖
股價往上走
走一走
成交量變少了
但因為看好它的人
沒有消失
股價後續
還是有力道繼續往上
但如果這檔股票
本來是下跌趨勢
那價漲量縮的意思
又完全不一樣了
你看這張圖
原本股價一直往下跌
突然反彈了一點
但成交量是變少
這代表什麼
代表沒有太多人願意跟進
股價看起來有漲
但上漲的力道其實很弱
這種情況我們叫它死貓跳
看起來好像要變強
但其實只是短暫的反彈
迴光返照騙你一下
講完上漲
接下來我們來看下跌
這邊真的要用心聽
因為碰到下跌的時候
成交量非常的重要
它可以提醒你
什麼時候要趕快離開
也可以幫你找到
股價準備反彈的機會
如果股價下跌
成交量也跟著變多
這個叫價跌量增
最常見也是
最需要小心的狀況是
股價原本一路
都在你設定的均線上面
結果突然開始跌
成交量也放大
股價跌到均線之下
而且後面
沒有很快地漲回來
這通常代表
有一批人
正在大量地賣出
原本上漲的趨勢
可能準備要反轉
變成下跌的趨勢
像這張圖
股價往下殺
成交量跟著越來越大
代表越來越多人在賣
如果你看得懂成交量
你很早就可以發現
欸 不對勁了
而不是等到
股價跌一大段
才後悔自己
沒有提早賣掉
但價跌量增
還有一種
比較有趣的狀況
它會出現在下跌的趨勢裡
也就是說
這檔股票
本來已經跌很深了
現在股價繼續往下跌
賣的人也很多
這時候你要記住一件事
每一張被賣出去的股票
都一定有一個買家去接手
有人大量賣出
同時也代表
有人大量買進
股價接下來
就有可能會出現
一波短暫的反彈可以賺
但注意
這裡不是叫你
看到就立刻買
而是要開始觀察
股價有沒有慢慢超過均線
後面有沒有人持續買
看清楚再出手
最後一種情況
叫做價跌量縮
股價下跌 成交量也變小
很多新手一看到股價跌
就會很害怕
如果這檔股票
前面漲了一段
整體趨勢還是偏向上漲
現在股價
只是稍微回落了一下
成交量也變小
那通常不用太緊張
因為這代表
沒有很多人急著逃跑
股價可能只是正常休息
休息完之後
還有機會往上走
但如果這檔股票
本來就是一個下跌的趨勢
那價跌量縮你就要小心了
因為這代表股價在跌
但是願意買的人也不多
沒有什麼人願意接手
價格就容易越跌越低
如果你第一次聽到
這四種量價關係
覺得有點陌生
記不住
很正常
我幫你把今天教的內容
整理成一張表格
你之後實際看股票的時候
可以拿出來對照
如果你想知道
什麼時候買進
股價比較容易
繼續往上漲
這四種情況裡面
我覺得最好用的
就是這兩種
第一個 價跌量縮
第二個 價漲量縮
股市裡有一句話叫做
量縮找買點
天量找賣點
那為什麼會說
量縮找買點
因為成交量變少
很多時候代表
股市正在降溫
如果股價上漲時量縮
可能代表大家
都看好這檔股票
不太願意賣
如果股價下跌的時候量縮
在上漲的趨勢裡
可能代表
沒有很多人急著賣掉股票
所以在量縮的時候
股價反而比較穩
後面比較容易重新往上走
那第二句話
天量找賣點是什麼意思
我先解釋一下
天量指的是
成交量突然放得
非常非常的大
尤其是股價
已經漲了很多之後
突然爆出很大的成交量
這時候就要很小心了
因為成交量很大
通常代表著股市裡面
同時有兩批人
第一批人
情緒很興奮
覺得這檔股票
還會繼續漲
所以想要趕快衝進去買
第二批人
可能是很早就買進去的人
他們覺得他們在
很便宜的時候就買了
看到現在股價漲很多了
就會想要趁熱
把股票賣掉
入袋為安
有些大戶他們會趁
很多人追進來的時候
慢慢把手上的股票賣出去
但如果這些大戶
賣完離開
後面的股價
常常就會撐不住
像這邊
所以很多熱門股
不太適合新手去追
你一追進去
很可能不是買在
剛開始上漲的位置
而是買在
別人準備離場的位置
不過風險高的地方
報酬率通常也很可觀
我自己會用
一套方法去判斷
到底是真的有資金
準備往上進攻
還是有人正在
等你進來接手
像這支寰宇 KY
你看它這幾段
成交量突然拉得非常高
但它前面其實就有透露出
幾個關鍵線索
所以我判斷它接下來
很有機會往上衝
我在這個點持續地加碼買進
最後到這邊
開始慢慢地出場
這段就成功地
獲利五十幾萬
這個判斷強弱股的方法
我會在免費的直播講座裡
跟你分享
同時我也會教你
很實用的
七種當沖獲利術
跟兩種飆股的選股法
現在就點擊
資訊欄連結報名
如果點進去
沒有看到報名按鈕
那就代表
目前暫時額滿了
如果你喜歡這幾天的影片
一樣幫我按讚 訂閱
開啟小鈴鐺
有問題也可以留言問我
我是小王子
我們下次見